مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره نشر
الامن التركي صوره لمن قال انها المشتبه
في تنفيذها عمليه تفجير في شارع الاستقلال
باسطنبول بعد ساعات من وقوعها كما حصلت
الجزيره على صوره لها من زوايا مختلفه
اثناء وجودها في ساحه تقسيم المؤديه الى
شارع الاستقلال وتبين الصور انها ترتدي
ملابس شبه عسكريه
قد قتل سته اشخاص اصيب واحد 81 بجروح في
التفجير الذي هزه شارع الاستقلال فقال
نائب الرئيس التركي ان التفجيره عمل
ارهابي ناجم عن تفجير امراه القنبله
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى ان
الحادثه ارهابي وقال ان التنظيمات
الارهابيه لن تتمكن من تركيع الدوله
عقد الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس الكوري الجنوبي
ورئيس الوزراء الياباني قمه ثلاثيه على
هامشي اعمال قمه رابطه الاسياد وقال
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان القاده
تتعهدوا برد المشترك على اي اختبار النووي
المحتمل لكوريا الشماليه اضاف ان رئيس بيض
اوضح خلال القمه انا نواشه جاهزه لمنافسه
قويه لجين لكنها لا تسعى الى النزاع معها
الرئيس السابقين وحلفائها بتقويض المصالح
موسكو وبجين في المحيط الهادي اكد رئيس
الاندونيسيا على ضروره ان لا تصبح منطقه
جنوب شرق اسيا مسرحا لصناعه الدوليه
بالوكاله
قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه لقواتها
صده محاولات الروسيه للتقدم في مقاطعه
ايدونيسكو مذكره مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيا
للقوات الروسيه تمكنت من احرازه تقدم من
طفيف على محور افديكا وان معارك وصفتها
بالعنيفه تدور على محور قتال مدينه
الاستراتيجيه
نقله عن مصادر مطلعه ان المستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جيكس صالبا ابلغ الرئيس
الاوكراني فلازم نسكي خلال لقائه في كييف
بضروره الانفتاح على المفاوضات ونقلته الى
السجن الان
اوصازنكي وفريقه بالبدا في التفكير في
مطالب واقعيه لما في ذلك اعاده النظر في
هدفه المعلن المتمثل باستعاده اوكرانيا
شبهه جزيره القرن قال كبير المفاوضين
الاوكرانيين بلاده لن تجد رساله طويله
المفاوضات نعم موسكو قبل تحقيقه شروطها
وهي استعاده جميع الاراضي والمحاسبه
المجرم الحرب
افادت وكاله سواء استشهد باحتفاظ
الديمقراطيه هنا بالاغلبيه البسيطه في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي بعد فوز مرشحه الحزب
كافرين ماستو بمقاعده المجلس عن ولايه
نيفادا في انتخابات التجديد النصفي وقال
الرئيس الامريكي جبيد ان نتائج تعبر عن
اراده الامريكيين ساب السياسه الاجتماعيه
لديمقراطيين بدوريا قالت رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي نصيبي لوسي انا نتائج الجمهوريين
في الانتخابات اقل من المتوقع
مشاهده شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]